so the topic that we have a geography
and scales of connectivity again and so
what we would also expect you know from
our panelist as well as you know the
respondent is a little bit of focus on
what those connectivities are you know
currently you know whether they're
working on you know that we've mentioned
the word boundaries right how those
boundaries are being challenged across
disciplines and time but you know
towards the end the real you know
purpose of this session is also to look
at how we can establish new forms of
connectivity and i think the word scale
you know when i looked at the program
and the details of the program for me
the word scale also meant you no sense
of urgency you know that we need to
react more quickly or we need to be on
the ground faster and so is that
something that we need to look at but
the other is also this two-way nature
you know of connectivity in Nepal we
often have a saying that nibblies are no
longer downloading but they are also
starting to upload and so you know it's
sort of in a uploading world you know
what does connectivity you know me so
without wasting any time I'm going to
give the floor and a first who gave it
and David you know again the bios are
all here but a PhD in geography at the
University of Hawaii and the east-west
Center and so you know you can be sure
that I am an engineer and I know how to
read my time very well and so maybe i
will give you a warning you know maybe
five year five minutes left and then
yeah let's just keep this moving into a
real two-way conversation David thank
you and you and good morning everyone
I'm honored to be here thanks to the
invitation and I'm a bit of a map nut
and rarely do my room with people who
are willing to listen to me talk about
math syllabus so thank you all for that
as well and the last panelist in the
session before is mentioned the mission
of maths from his presentation because
of time constraints some
make up for that as well so I've several
things I plan to do here but I want to
tie my maps to the work I've been doing
and also to the larger questions that
this assembly is geared towards us all
so 1737 Malaysia show up on the map this
is a map by French cartographer and it's
not much of a cartographic review they
appear but a smudge of squiggles off the
edge of the map but still win unless
they appear it ushered in really a
period of a couple of centuries of
exploration and through a lot of field
explorations and studies on the ground
beginning to get a better sense I guess
of the geography of the Himalaya
locations of places features of the
landscape features of human society and
so forth and eventually this sort of
evolved within the territorial expansion
of empires involving people some of whom
need no introduction the man on the
right so George Everest with the great
trigonometric survey the guy on the left
is an interesting character for me as an
artist and a spy painter and Kashmir who
would conduct surveys up in that Western
Himalaya region and secret them in the
canvases of his paintings and slip them
back to see London where they ended up
in the archives of the in the office
collections and it was very interesting
to go into those collections and take
his paintings and look at where you put
those maps and kind of bring all of this
to life was an enjoyable experience for
me but in the end what we had was an
effort that has continued through time
and brings really mapping up into my own
work beginning in those early days or
tripods amazing feats really people
climbing 20,000 21,000 foot mountains in
a day's work we have satellites to do a
lot of this kind of work these days and
and I in my own work have employed both
kind of ground-based mathy hand mapping
is
was a satellite-based mapping and in the
midst of this expansion of frontiers and
the mapping of territory the
determination of what's in these
landscapes and the identification of
boundaries is all kinds of contests
stations have developed among in between
different emerging countries in the
Himalaya region and I just have an
interesting little aside that links this
to my own work in the late 1990s I was
involved an ambitious project to
assemble a huge amount of data and
produce atlas of the Himalaya and in the
process of doing that collaborating with
people throughout the range but very
importantly the folks at EC mode basanta
shrestha random bunch of Sharia people
involved in the GIS see remote sensing
programs so over a couple of year period
collaborating with those folks and and
others creating these maps East mode was
interested in it and they wanted to
produce an initial version of the Atlas
so I put together materials and I say I
but actually I'm more of a conceptual
cartographer the real GG is genius
behind all of this was a colleague of
mine that is it here Joseph Pacheco but
in the end we put together an array of
maps with the assistance of the folks at
east mode and others and AC mode was
going to produce and publish the first
version and we sent them to Katmandu and
they disappeared for about 10 months and
we're wondering what happened to all of
this you know and I'm emails back and
forth and what basically happened was
that they were being distributed and
discussed amongst the constituent
countries of Asia mode all of whom have
different ideas of where their
boundaries are in the Himalaya and in
the end AC mode published the Atlas
without boundaries so it's an eccentric
Atlas so you could probably still get
your hands on one in Katmandu it may be
the only Atlas that exists as no
international
at all it was the only way they could
resolve the differences within the board
that was running EC mode but there are
other things to think about in terms of
these boundaries beyond just my problems
with this Atlas many of us are caught
into publication disclaimers if we use
maps that were involved in Mali area if
you want to have them appear in India or
China or Pakistan or na call you have to
put these kinds of words on these maps
certainly a much deeper level its border
conflicts between an among various
countries but also in another way a lot
of my work has to do with environmental
systems human environment relations
natural systems ecological processes and
these you know follow rules of their own
that have perhaps nothing to do with
international boundaries or boundaries
within countries so the dilemma of
reconciling Land Management landscape
ecology based studies that crossed
boundaries becomes an issue and crosses
borders and this is kind of evoked
different ways to think about landscape
and to involve the collaborations of
different countries involved I've just
learned from aneel the other day of a
new part Mount Kailasa Center in Mount
Kailasa which involves a cooperation of
China and Nepal and India an earlier
project I was involved with the tarai
arc project along the southern Nepal
India border also involved
collaborations between India and Nepal
so in a sense of natural systems work
and environmental and ecological systems
land landscape ecology based work the
effort to try to resolve these
geopolitical differences to come up with
some sort of coherent way of managing
the landscape I think is an important
consideration for us the the term scale
comes up a lot of newly introduced scale
we've heard it many times and it in my
own work I've moved through various
scales and scale doesn't matter a great
deal in terms
appian not just mapping but in terms of
the way that we approach a problem and
even try to come up with a way of
studying and analyzing it my my earliest
work which continues to a certain extent
has been a village based approach and
living in western nepal for a year for
example Wayne bundles of firewood and
baskets of fodder and baskets of animal
dung trying to get some kind of
empirical handle on relationships
between village life and the local
natural ecosystems and how people were
conceptualizing their relationship to
the landscape in terms of land
management and even conservation efforts
so the photograph on the Left fear is of
this village or region within the
village and an area that has experienced
and still is experiencing some serious
environmental degradation related to
slope problems and land management
problems and geomorphic processes
generally and then the map on the right
which is a field map a very crude field
map that that I produce that was showing
how villagers were really setting aside
different pieces of land to manage in a
particular way that in fact this is a
village based conservation approach to
land management that had really little
to do with outside intervention it was a
way of coming to terms with the changing
circumstances of the world and
regulating the use of the landscape
according to their knowledge of the
consequences of their use in the early
to mid-1990s extending through i guess
the decades of the 90s i shifted to a
much much larger scale actually a
regional scale at that time in geography
and associated disciplines the notion of
a himalayan environmental crisis just
around the corner becoming what was
called I guess loosely the Himalaya
environmental degradation theory I was
involved in a long project to try to get
kind of a spatial empirical assessment
of the ability of that it's based on a
lot of discrete observations oftentimes
roadside observations and so we were
working at a scale that was very
different from my earlier work at a
village level we working with
quantitative data sets and pre-record
Atta sets that were available oftentimes
at political unit scales but nonetheless
the effort was try to discern patterns
across the region that might lead to
certain kinds of questions that then
could be approached at a more local
scale in particular places so the map
you're looking at here is is one showing
for example forest change over over
periods of time in different parts of
the region the working at both village
levels with with issues such as
landslides and different kinds of
environmental events that were posing
risks to human life a livelihood led to
interests in natural hazards mapping for
me I have one example of these which is
based upon earthquake potential and land
that type of thing you know those of you
who spent a lot of time in Katmandu
these days it's hard not to imagine the
consequences of an earthquake and even
myself whether go to captain and do it
is actually affected my behavior quite
frankly where I even stay in terms of I
don't stay on the top floors high rise
buildings anymore I try to get within
jumping room of the ground and hopefully
you're an open area which is kind of
bizarre but nonetheless it's happening
so for the folks who are living there
you know you can't think about this it
would just drive you crazy but it is a
very real phenomena so these kinds of
maps are helpful the one on the left is
a region-wide kind of seismicity
potential and the other one has to do
with kathmandu valley valley you know
it's it's a sediment based landscape
that when it starts to shake and
actually liquefy which is a frightening
prospect
anyways when you think about putting
structures on that type of of a surface
in the late 1990s and early 2000s my
interest in maps started shifting quite
a bit and actually my interest in
geography generally started shifting
quite a bit I was interested more in the
maps that we hold in our minds and these
maps are maps that not only help us
understand the world but our place in
the world how to navigate through the
world so these are important maps for us
they are part and parcel to our
geographical imagination and they also
have an imprint on the landscape but in
some cases an inadvertent imprint in
some cases a very conscious explicit
imprint but nonetheless Lee the
transference of it so a geographical
imagination to a landscape became an
interesting phenomena for me so I went
to shangri-la to to look at this
shangri-la has come up in a number of
presentations in New York with the new
school my approach was I went back into
James Hilton's book Lost Horizon 1933
Woodward shangri-la first appeared and
started identifying key descriptors of
landscape features that became important
in that book and then whipped to this
area of northwestern univ ins that a
chinese geographer had actually
determined to be the actual shangri-la
and the landscape features in that
region that correspond or analogous to
victim landscape features in the book
collar gable for example is caro cool
soon technique monastery as a shangri-la
monastery you begging valley for example
as a shangri-la valley itself and
looking at this I guess in I have to say
in a certain way as a source of interest
for me curiosity for me but as I started
looking at it in terms of tourism
development and to understand how you
could tank a fictive landscape that's
produced in the Western literature and
translated into tours and promotional
material
and develop an economy based upon that
is quite a remarkable thing that's being
achieved and again with all kinds of
implications but the photograph on the
bottom right suggests that there are
some some risks when you start to to do
this in the features that may be
associated with very real cultural
identities become amusements this risk
is is very much a part of critical
tourism literature and I was simply
looking at in the case of this part of
China I also thought about using
photography in a little deeper way I am
a photographer by I guess by inclination
and then by training to a certain Stan a
self-taught photographer but over time
I've spent a lot of serious time working
on photography but one of the ways that
I've used photography is is to repeat
photography method where I get old
photographs from different parts of the
kamalia from different sources the
British sources American sources of
climbers in this case geographer
pradyuman got on all current from Bhutan
1964 and then going back to that same
spot and repeating that spot with a new
photograph what that provides me is a
photo pair that on the one hand can can
discern changes in the landscape which
is which is interesting and you could
actually do a relatively detailed study
of that but I used these more as as
tools because on the one hand locating
that perspective was a wonderful process
involving local people using them as
guides into the landscape to try to find
this perspective to photograph again but
then using the photo pair back in the
field as a as a prompt for life history
collect
it's a it was a great way and is a great
way for people to recall cultural memory
a wonderful way quite frankly that can
that can cross generations and it
provided for me a very very rich source
of both landscape information and also
ethnographic information in the form of
of life histories so that approach I
utilized in Bhutan Katmandu valley as
well and over in the Kulu Valley which
were three areas that I had access to 20
full address in the case of Bhutan from
the 1960s but in the case of Kathmandu
Valley working with the family archives
of the tutor car family who were the
chroniclers of the of the Durbar the
courtroom and Paul kid and monitor car
holds those archives in his house on the
fourth floor was mawari home a brick
houses could topple like a deck of cards
he's very concerned about the archival
issue of holding this record because it
is an enormous historical record prior
to the advent of photography technology
his ancestors were the painters of the
course so he has also a tremendous
collection of very very beautiful old
paintings so I was able to use his
collections and then in the Western
Himalaya collections out Library of
Congress and also the Royal Geographical
Society but with essentially the same
idea of mine too to see the landscape as
a sort of map and in a way that map then
reflects the imprint of humankind on a
landscape I see the landscape as both a
repository of human history and most
importantly the relationship between
human history and environmental history
natural history it's very important for
me that connection that comes through in
a landscape and also to see the
landscape early as a mirror of the
intentions historically the intentions
of people living in a place and the
creation of that place for there so what
I do now is very different than what i
was doing 25 years ago in terms of what
I'm interested in
as I've taken the methods I use and
where I study but they all in a certain
way now revolve around the notion of
landscapes landscapes as Maps the visual
production of a mental map as a
landscape and how this then holds
certain treasures of cultural memory
that can be extracted from from the
landscape and from photographing the
landscape thank you very much ok so
since you want collage us to dwarf on
maternal from our own research I had
decided to prison concrete examples and
to reduce a chronology of part of the
research I have been carving out as a
geographer in the Himalayas as you will
see it is linked to changes in scale and
I combine questions from several panels
and this will help to see some of the
research trends in my discipline over
the past 20 years before going any
further I would like to point out that
having trained in physical geography in
geomorphology and having worked within a
team of social anthropologist agronomist
historians and botanists since i started
my research in the Himalayas I have only
ways privileged a mentally physically
approach when i started my fieldwork in
nepal at the beginning of the 80s result
i was dominated by what eyes and miserly
called the theory of himalayan and by
120 gradation a theory that emerged in
the nineteen seventies with the first
result in millions in the area to sum up
a catastrophic see now in your predicted
that given the search of demographic
roles after the 1950s a growing demand
for three resources as well as for fam
lon would leave you would lead to
massive deforestation hands to
catastrophic increase in seoul erosion
the loss of productive lands to
accelerated landslide incidence and the
loss of sulfur tility all processes say
to cause devastating floods in the
Ganges and Brahmaputra plane works for
which himalayan peasants have
held responsible it was predicted that
in the year 2000 there will be no
accessible forest cover in Nepal and
that was of a pastoral system prevalent
there would not have survived the
scenario upheld by the hypothesis for
research sorry carried out at the time
in this region of the world and since I
myself work in German faraji part of my
task was to document it well numerous
studies have been questioned this
catastrophe stairway and much I've been
written about it so I will not develop
this here but will only give two
examples to show how in-depth studies
have questions is merely the first
example concerns who have attack was
carried out alongside physical
investigations about the media in German
further decline mythology and the like
at that time results from ecology and
physical geography were mainly based on
short periods of the world more than
that not is they had no historical death
and there were few details to this to
show the relationship between population
and the milieu by combining an
topological and geographical approaches
I have conducted another kind of
research the idea was to stay for a
world year in a village in order to have
pre and both the rhythms of nature and
the rism of society and above all the
interaction it was at a hmong village
Dalmane worker district in central nepal
where indefinitely disciplinary research
was conducted the parallel to the germ
of illogical work and say here one of
the outcomes of this research was some
work on toponyms or place names it was
rooted in a large amount of data
physical historical socio-economic
religious provided by the villagers the
Khmers stories and anecdotes about the
place names were recorded and author and
the meaning of the top names of
themselves the translation and as a
symbolization and this map over at sea
data were collected to provide
information on the
the other place it's the section its
representation and for the natural
resources mentioned on their use all
these so on this map all place place
names are represented by a symbol will
activities are my name's mags nads
dignities of the soil as well as places
where there is too much water or where
there are certain kinds of 368 era our
maps all this has been very useful in
understanding the population
relationship to its environment the way
people use it the resources the select
the place is avoid the link with a
design in the world the way they
consider territory that is to say here's
a space used and appropriated by the
population so along with our
investigation this 2d sorry this 2 d's
has shown the intimate knowledge before
half of that unstable menu the
maintenance to carry out on it as well
as a symbolic and religious dimension
this video has for them this was a
contribution to local knowledge studies
that emerged at that time to
counterbalance the theory of America
under mental degradation yet the purpose
of this study was not to failure local
knowledge of the scientific data but we
do them to complement each other a set
of examples that show the inaccuracy of
the theory of mi anandamide big
reduction is a study that focused on
goomy agra contient alpha district in
the Western runoff of Nepal at the end
of the 1980s and in the 1990s there we
try to move on from monographs to
regional studies working on a regional
scale yet still relying on in-depth
studies on village scale we showed that
why the forest has dwindled or has been
protected people have counted the number
of trees around there fills to satisfy
their needs constituting in some places
a real good cash with non-sexist they
have selected a variety of trees both
for folder all year round from trees of
the best quality and for firewood and
timber we recorded more than 50
varieties of for the triple farm to
secure the slope they have in a
cause to be fed and therefore more more
milk to do produce which is sold on the
battle what is more the resources to be
found next to the house therefore the
loudness discourse about the drug view
of productivity associated with a
declining florist needed to be
reconsidered the same statement was made
at that time by scholars such as dr.
Forbes Gilmore Fisher etc so before
going any further we can see that these
two examples highlight two points the
first is that depending on the way we
consider objects of research worked on
very different results the shift since
the beginning of research in the
Himalayas has been from ecological
biological or physical studies to
environment or studies this means that
the object studied had notably been
ecological geomorphic not natural things
in themselves but resources / sex
constituents risks in planning the devil
reference to nutshell and societies the
specials forest trees lumps like and
water are therefore considered among
under not on point of view that is as
socially invested natural objects the
second point follows on from this one it
refers to the choice of the scale of
work both in time and space between a
global and short-term scale go bring the
xbox crop more firm which is often
disconnected with from the population
needs and a local and long term scale
which helps to provide knowledge while
taking into account that of village
communities in the second case I have
presented shifting from forest 23 does
not amount to a simple change in scale
the focal distances is not the same and
the results of them are different these
few elements for consideration touch
upon problems raised by my voice Louie
as I clever wrote in a book entitled
judicial which can be translated by
playing with scale I quote the choice of
a particular scale of observation
produces effects of knowledge and label
and may be put to the service of
knowledge strategies adjusting the Lance
[ __ ] not only increases or reduces
the size of the object in the other but
Zhang Jian shed its shape and
sure Oh using another refill and system
playing with representation scales in
cartography does not come down to
represent a consistent reality any
bigger or smaller but to transforming
the content of the representation that
is to say that shows of white is
represented oh la creme quote these
statements are of particular importance
to him around studies since they have
often been accused of being founded on
long-term monographs yet when it would
reconsider under mental issues the local
scale is essential for understanding
situations of course we then have to
play around with scale switching from
one to another now another stage in
research has been to show that even
though the theory of the magnetometer
degradation has been highly criticized
by many scholars it has so far strongly
influenced environment or policies and
this is what I am considering
four-decade also one of its main effects
has been to operate a clear separation
between nature and society on different
scales this is a current transfer in the
world it is based on Vermont old
paradigm built at International and
national levels and shared by various
back actors will consider by enlarge
that natural has to be protected from
societies that will only destroy it and
would therefore claim the need for clear
separation between these two
ontologically redefine entities one of
the points I would like to make here is
that during part 2 these environmental
conceptions over the last 30 years until
Morales we have witnessed segregation
and specialization of space by setting
up of a new under mental boundaries
which have led to territorial changes
and territorial restrictions here I will
not develop what had happened in a
village scale suffice to say that the
igual silver pastoral system that was
still at work in many places of the ones
in the 18th and which was characterized
by the fact that all me
use both cultivated areas as well as
forests were put to some use in the
complaint complimentary manner so this
system has been modified the trick
protection of Flores in the 1980s along
with other changes such as demographic
growth so dropped in manpower due to the
scrolling of the young generation to
Alcon aggression and political conflicts
have led in many places to a
restructuring of village territories and
the villagers territoriality in order to
reduce the time needed to access
resources farming activities are now
often good around the thumbs dead fields
have been grouped together common
grazing is on the decline and animals
are kept in stalls with what a trunk
installed in some places to water the
cattle so far west is used less and less
and we can observe a more distinct
separation between forest which most
open up protective and in a between
activity derive this situation can be
found to varying degrees houses on 20
Morales in the history Malaya's in
arunachal pradesh for example we're
shifting slash-and-burn cultivation is
predominant over the last decade they
have been project aim at abundant exist
practice that is seen as a threat to the
environment to the environment and at
settling populations which have led to
terrorizing slots and consequently to a
total redefinition of populations
practices and other territories here
again these changes have introduced a
new kind of division between society and
nature with a specialization of space
now on a state scale since the 1970s
another important consequence of this
theory of immigrant not underwater
degradation has been the city yet of
numerous protected areas such as
national parks biosphere reserves while
x + 2 areas and the life on my panties
flower on this map with the damn also in
order to protect the environment they
cover more than thirty percent of the
total himalayan area in this study the
scale of observation as child the whole
ranch has been taken into consideration
even though
still favor local scale approach for
in-depth studies focusing on Kaziranga
National Park in Assam the aim is to
look at the way this protected areas
have reshaped the geography of the
Himalayas and that what is at stake here
this protected areas also operate a
clear divide between nature and society
and one of the points in studying flame
has been to demonstrate how as unclaimed
within States highlands of nature and
with new environmental borders they
constitute new on by mental territories
at the heart of debates that are not
merely limited to natural protection
issues for me some aspect of these
studies of national parks actually
contribute to borders 2 d's and the
world's written better than concerned
about the border between Bangladesh and
India may be applied to any part of the
study focuses on the infernal boundaries
constituted by this particular area and
undermining the crystallized made me
conflict for example is one boundaries
alfin surrounded by the army and a
better protected at international
borders there is a kind of battle field
around this boundary between man and
animal the so-called mine while in life
conflict they may also be
instrumentalized by by activists and
play the role of other borders this is a
case for example of Kaziranga National
Park Bo the way for activists Hindu
nationalist fighting against bangladeshi
migrants or in other words against
Muslims the fence surrounding the
National Park is a replica on another
scale of the world between Bangladesh
and India the lyrics of the following
song sang at one of these events in
straight sixes please oh sorry please
just pay attention to the last verse the
whole text Laura flies natural and get
drunk at National Park and that's again
we see how it is used now a thought
process is in keeping with the job rush
of hunger by a pedir I who shows how
tension between India and Pakistan
clears in Newton films at various levels
and on various scales this also echoes a
study conducted by Emma mostly on the
case of Tara dam and the world Hindu
conceal a militant nationalist
organization was rhetoric which is used
to protest against the dance
constriction his lead is linked to untie
my slim action this association between
civilians a cell phone is not uncommon
EDM Vermonters issues in India and as
shown by Renisha and maudsley in the
Himalayas ecological degradation had
become a metaphor for the degradation of
both quality and culture all these
conflicts were particularly as few
numerous other conflicts in the ranch
and noticeably those ready to claims to
autonomous territories this is a case of
the machine living on the fringe of
Kaziranga National Park as was a case
elsewhere in Assam of the boodles
regarding minez national park on the
border with gluten well over all these
years given the failure of natural
protection read and speak separation
between nature and society attempts have
been made to solve the problems
reflection has been fueled by different
communities from x12 develop of
development civil society to scholars
and several trends have succeeded each
other so with regard to various
conceptions about what under model
policies should be in the Himalayas we
have gone from one explicative story to
another one not to say sometimes from
one meet one other although they have
all contributed some positive aspects
and have been helpful in questioning the
prevailing theory of Himalayan and
protection under matter degradation and
in reintroducing society natural
protection policies they have also shown
their limits and pitfalls because they
have a fun been considered in
distinctively this is well documented in
argentina rocky books about temperament
in the Himalayas what I would say that
today so that different problems with
with a local knowledge and with Allison
virgin 20 months for the sake of
conservation which and it might be
helpful but
so it would be very pitiful so how would
say that today we should be careful
about another emerging theory that
dominates our research in the Himalayas
that of Thai mentioned and its
consequences on water resources for the
Himalayan population I am currently
working on such project in Nepal in the
combo area so constriction of the
climate champagne that scenario is very
similar to the construction of the
theory of Himalayan anti-monitor
degradation even though it is based on
really alarming data it is also found in
on the cell catastrophic discourse it
often holds email and villagers practice
responsible for this climate change
it'll of the same mid knows they are
already androids of international
organization acting in this field and I
will add it is also already generates in
the lot of business even before in
appdata have been collected to analyze
it here again the local scale is
essential from understanding of the
process realize this when we work with
analogies hydrologist or both working on
models were actually very far from the
local situation so to an with regard to
the question about whether the Himalayas
can be category for analysis I will say
that over the last 30 years along with
the numerous dams that have been built
for texted areas are modifying the
geography of the ranch on a scale of the
Indian subcontinent the Himalayas are
more and more limited to the role of
wizard a cultural reserve a natural
reserve and a water tower to supply the
rest of India whatever our scale of
observation we are seeing an
accentuation of the split between nature
and society this is true on the scale of
the round like I had shown then within
the space with the setting up of
particular areas when there is a speed
between protected Metis and inhabited
meteors and finally on a scale of the
mountain slopes whereas it is a growing
between fairways and in a bt den
conservative areas on an album register
though sometimes linked autonomous
territories also take part in this
process of differentiation and
specialization of space versus the
Himalayas
and environmental policies some of the
population has been displaced has become
our clothes and co-chairs of butchers
and has suffered from degradation caused
by wildlife venturing outside the
perimeter of protected areas this is
reported for our the ranch in many
places it contributes to a drop in
agricultural yields and two people
abandon inland this is one of the
problem himalayan peasants have to face
today I will defer view that this aspect
of environment and development policies
Here I am given only the negative points
that they are off course or so many
positive ones so these aspects as well
as a conflict associated with them have
inner way reinforce the Himalayan entity
which in my point of view constitute a
valid category that deserves to be
studied within the area and with other
areas of the world and i will add to
this focusing on its internal borders
thank you i must say it was pleasure
listening to all the panel members as i
was sitting down I was having some
clearly some trouble trying to frame
this five-minute talk because it's on
the fly so so I have made several
categories that I think might be useful
for us to think through as we discuss
the representations in this in this in
this panel and one of the categories
that jump to my mind is the as or the
common theme that jumps in my mind is
the is boundaries and scales but across
nature and culture and
across different geographical societies
my own work is is a highlight this
particular thing of nature and culture
my work is with is on snow levels I look
at the human wildlife conflict between
snow leopards and Himalayan farmer if
snow leopard is one species that really
connects the entire Himalayas not the
Tiberian of the Rhino it's a small
diaper gratifying from Bhutan to the
Western Himalayas in Pakistan so I can
perhaps peak of this this nature culture
dichotomy that has been a very prominent
feature of representations of Himalayas
and Amelia's environment in our my work
i look at the connection that snow
leopard which is considered a very
mythical and elusive creature of the
high Himalayas of the wilderness owner
of the Christian representing film major
and it's connection with domestic
economy that is local people and as we
have already heard in various
presentations the way the question of
environment the way the question of
sustainability is framed there is an
implicit division or implicit boundary
that is created between nature and
society and that has led to many wrong
prescriptions perhaps as well as
policies that are afflicted the nations
and societies across the Himalayas today
and what I found out in my own work that
in order to sort of past this boundary
in order to look at the traffic across
this artificial boundary we really need
to work at the very basic look and level
so then we come to the issue of scales
so in order to pass this myth of nature
culture boundary which is not only
a physical manifestation but also is the
way we conceptualize the world it's also
in metaphysical idea and hence at a very
metaphysical level or metaphysical scale
in order to break this down as as or
challenge it we need to really grow and
work at the very basic level so what I
do is I connect snow leopard shape and
I've been collaborating with wildlife
biologists and one of the things that I
try to do is in that [ __ ] I look at how
much of its prey is based on domestic
livestock and based on that one can then
argue that this mythical creature is
actually dependent on human society so
it turns out about thirty to forty
percent of snow leopard diet comes from
domestic livestock but the way
conservation policies and protectionist
policies are construed they tend to
ignore this particular traffic across
nature at culture boundary and think
that because snow leopard is this
mythical creature it doesn't have to do
anything with the domestic economy and
this ignoring of this problem leads to
conflict which wildlife biologist earned
as human-wildlife conflict but as social
scientists as anthropologists we call it
as human human conflict over over wide
life so in this panel I was really
heartened to see that we have challenged
this particular boundary of nature and
culture didn't leave you your family and
environmental degradation be in the
election production of knowledge and as
anthropologist I can for her perhaps
speak about methodology as well as a
theoretical framework that we have used
to challenge this this boundary for
example in theory of Himalayan
environmental degradation political
ecology and the and the role of an
apologist in looking at political
ecology has been phenomenal they have
shown that local level environmental
degradation are caused by contradiction
in policies at global regional and
national levels just that has also led
to the need for connection across
various scales of knowledge of
communities of knowledge be at the local
level be at the region level or at the
at the national level there is clearly
as as we heard from our speaker there is
a need for boundary crossing for all of
us and if I can use the anthropological
term that boundary crossings are usually
transformative they are transformative
for us as scholars so when I work with
wildlife biologist I have to see the
world through their eyes I have to
really try to understand and also put
myself in this framework that the
Himalayas are devoid of any human beings
or there are only while and natural
landscape that needs to be assessed or
that needs to be describes and these are
very disconcerting moments at these
moments it is difficult to keep your own
disciplinary identity your own
professional identity and and that has I
think been a big challenge especially
for social scientists what I have
noticed that we tend to perhaps ignore
or we tend to not take many other
Sciences for example physical sciences
for what they are and engage in in
criticizing them rather making some
pragmatic use of them but having said
that I think there is more and more
literature that is coming out which is
an especially in anthropology which is
trying to write ethnographies are trying
to produce literature which doesn't not
only have academic value but where as
well as practical value so for example
in the case of environmental movement
and conservation movement more and more
anthropologists are sort of setting
aside the basic problem in anthropology
of crisis of representation how do we
make representations of you know
indigenous societies or how do we
represent and and they have sort of left
this question aside and now are talking
about that perhaps we need to make more
representations we need to make
politically astute representations and
in that context they have I think in
some ways been successful at jumping
boundaries collaborating with wildlife
biologists collaborating with historians
collaborating with with people
especially in in Natural Sciences and I
think when you're thinking through these
papers it might also be interested in
interesting to think about temporal
scales because we are talking about
Himalayas and him alia invoke this
spatial imagery in her mind and I think
David David Zurich when he is talking
about shangri-la it was very interesting
that a category that was perhaps
Khanzada 8090 years ago in a different
time zone is now becoming relevant in
the contemporary contemporary era so I
guess I just end at this I don't have
any specific question to offer I was
asked to perhaps synthesize some of the
talks that were presented so thank you
very much
well thank you very much very
interesting presentations on the
Border's particularly on when you try to
contest this borders you know there is a
very significant conspicuous and a very
tangible train going on in the entire
league mullen region which I read how to
transform this borders which remain
totally security centric so far into a
borders of opportunities and is a very
well known very well planned designed by
the respective governments international
agencies like a db2 an escape and World
Bank to really bring some such kind of
transformations if you see starting from
the extremists animalyzer right there's
a very well planned initiative going on
in order to revive the steel well road
during the Second World War connecting
on the basis of sub regionalism
countries the geographically contiguous
regions like Bangladesh northeast of
India China you know the southwestern
part of China and mine and if you go in
between this the middle the part you
will find linking not to LA with sue
came with Tibet Autonomous Region with
the road Rhodey job and last number of
such kind of interactions between the
park between himachal pradesh and China
if you go to the western part you will
find a very well designed programmed to
link water port Karakorum and Pakistan
and the Chinese right now given this
this is going to and this is likely to
happen in the course of next 10 to 15
years the plans are already output
agencies are working some of the things
out already now given this kind of a set
of traditions a set of interactions
existed now here is Kara in the name of
trade investment energy tourism
you know transport communications you
have this kind of transformative
activities going on Chinese bringing
railway lines to across the other side
of the secure means border railway lines
up to tato pani and Nepal riding cut
what what as as social scientists has
Democritus and of course as
cartographers what kind of what kind of
bored do you force or what kind of
boredom and do you force in terms of
interactions among the people on both
sides of the motors makes a good
question let me just hold on let's take
the three and then maybe you know there
are commonalities it's just a way to say
thank you for your presentations I had a
question from joelle I appreciated your
talk and your emphasis that all of a
succession of policies have tended to
reinforce the dichotomy of nature and
culture and as you know I'm a great fan
of the tour the tour we say that this is
not ontological II really doable and
that the monsters will pop up somehow
there will be a monster that the
contradiction of this will emerge
somehow and I wondered where are the
monsters okay my question is
specifically for David David I really
really we track baby excuse me which
baby ultramon oh yes sorry other game I
want to ask about the ethics of the
digital archive and how you deal with
the informed consent process when you're
doing ethnography to post something
online I've had difficulty with a
band-pass second how do you deal with
the digital divide or the translation of
the information on the local level okay
so three good questions
then this would be perfect Mike hello
I'll dress first first gentleman's
question I don't know in terms of a pan
Himalaya conceptualization of a border
but anecdotally I would say this last
fall I was up in a tree soo Lee Valley
one of these roads is being built by the
Chinese and is connecting Tibetan and in
May Paul and as it may well be done as
we sit here they were getting very close
to it and shooting off from that road up
into lung tung and some of the side
valleys there was a lot of discussion
about the impact of road on the border
activities of those people displacing
for example entrepreneurial small-scale
entrepreneurial efforts that were
already in place having to do with trade
and movements of goods and people and so
forth that that these small-scale
activities wouldn't be able to
economically viable with with with the
new road and so the concern men becomes
do you try to position oneself along the
roadway and take advantage of this flow
or do you just lose so these roads as
part of international infrastructures
will connect large regions but they may
well bypass local territorial
relationships would be one reaction to
that yo for this world I would think
that's for example in northeast India it
will change everything yeah because as
some of these places which were
completely removed not completely but
which will remote and separated from the
rest of India now was it will be linked
to the rest of the South East Asia by
the road which is built which is being
built now so it will change a lot
everything it is already changing so for
the other question about about culture
and and natural i will say that actually
rather as a ponte site anyway since all
this cindy split between nature and
society is lead to the fact that juries
are many many conflicts and more and
more
and the people now in kaziranga national
park for example now where I am working
a lot they don't want to hear any longer
about Tiger project about about national
parks and so on so and they are going to
on the the address reading activists and
so they are just fighting again that so
it's a real failure so the point that to
not take into consideration the link
between nature and culture is really
something which is bringing more and
more conflict i would say they're into
lunch so nice the morning maybe yeah so
the first question i don't think i have
anything special say about mainly
informed consent that is a challenge
especially when you're dealing with
people that you have to explain the
whole dissemination process that you're
asking for permission for and so what we
try to do is explain to them what the
consequences of that are alert them to
possible concerns they might have give
them an opt-out strategy then also
proactively screen the content ourselves
for any potential problem even if they
think there isn't so as far as the
digital divide goes that relates to both
production and dissemination so in terms
of production one thing we've been
trying to focus on is we have three
centers in Tibetan areas in machining
and Chengdu and masa where we actually
have full-time University of Virginia
staff who are working with local
communities and so in terms of the
production and dissemination side we're
trying we have actual output outpost
there and I didn't get to the final
slide where I talked about the challenge
for why we have so many dysfunctional
people within higher education and I
think it's because we keep hiring people
that are like us and because we've
created a fetish out of a certain notion
of what research is and so we say this
is research we're so sorry minorities
and women and all these other people
that aren't represented adequately in
the Academy you don't qualify but really
that's about our values that have
expressed themselves in that
configuration of research and so I would
like to see us think about engagement as
a category that's part of research and
gets factored into promotion tenure
hiring committees and so when you're
working with local communities on
facilitating knowledge production as
well as offering different kinds of
programs of engagement my question would
be is intellectual knowledge uniquely
require for that activity if it is then
it should count as research and what's
the impact that it's having on the
overall state of the integrity and
extent of the knowledge that we have
also in terms of dissemination to try to
build a system even if those communities
don't have online access if you build a
system that has multiple output formats
someone could output those in a form
that's appropriate to the technical
facility they have what they could be
paper or it could be a DVD or it could
be a thumb driver it could be whatever
format can be reached to that community
and then you actively take care for that
by having university centers in the in
the in the communities that you have a
long-term relationship with so that's a
short answer okay so you know we're
going to you know they break for lunch
and so I think you know I'll hand it
over to Andrew but just you know to do
the work of the chair you know to really
thank our wonderful families the
respondent and also the audience but
also to thank our hosts you know for
having us all here
you learn you know in all this
discussion is that hungry people are
angry people the black is for too long
well let me just repeat Anil's thanks to
these wonderful rich and provocative
presentations to respondents to our
chairs into our audience we are now
officially adjourned